he's the most successful player
north american counter-strike has ever
seen they're flying by the seat of their
pants
and stewie's here to take advantage of
it he's blind but that doesn't matter
the chosen one given the task of
bringing glory to an entire
region stewie he's come for the knife
he's gonna go for it he does it stewie
he might find this clutch and he goes
again for more
it's trading back and forth for stewie
and within his first year of competitive
play
stewie took cloud nine to the top of the
world stewie's on his own but look at
the time
look at the time there's seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie but after making history and
earning any of their
first major title he turned his sights
to a new challenge
definitely after the major win he's a
player you have to look at and say he's
very adaptable very versatile as a
player
i mean he's just climbed like that you
click your fingers he's on a stage like
this
he was supposed to be the one to come in
with the experience of winning the major
and be able to get them over that hump
so now this is gonna be a test
nitro is ready damage done can't quite
find enough though it's a double kill
the stewie2k
this is the story of how na superstar
developed as a versatile leader
and made history once again
[Applause]
in 2018 stewie2k became one of the most
prolific american counter-strike players
in history when he won the boston major
with cloud9
and then just two months later he left
to join sk
gaming a roster filled with some of the
best players counter-strike has ever
seen
and it turned out to be his biggest
challenge yet sk has always been a top
team
we've always looked up to them i've
always watched their demos we copy a lot
from them so
i think they know what they're doing and
following has always been pictured as
a great igl one of the best and cold one
of the best players in the world if not
the best
so now i think the next step in my
career to learn more is just learning
from them
on the team but joining this team meant
that stewie would have to become more of
a support player
something that he hadn't really been
known for in the past
from copy commits to that despite being
blind stewie moving in
he's actually finding some decent impact
here terexil's position on the side too
what is this one stewie just picking
these players off one by one right now
oh
my god another one now onto next two
leggy
he's the last hope here in a 1v1 no
stewie single-handedly aces against big
on c9 stewie had been a leader but sk
already had a legendary igl
and that left many wondering why he was
opting to become a role player
what kind of like bottles my mind is
that he chose to join a
sk where you're you're not going to be a
star player on this game
you're not gonna be more
impact than fur you're not gonna be more
impact than cold zero if he
actually does the role player role like
if he does it right
they're gonna be unstoppable absolutely
coming in stewie's the only one in there
and he's got an mp9
he's gonna get flashed in he's gonna
just go for it he's gonna go for it
oh my god stewie
but despite some wins at tier two events
the roster
didn't live up to expectations they just
couldn't perform when it mattered most
we've seen him do magical things with
smokes he's gonna get tagged over the
top of it and up close nothing's there
to find him fur
14 hp doesn't expect the wrap round
sonny drops him and mouse sports
they're gonna do it they close out this
series in june of 2018
immortals acquired the sk gaming roster
and rebranded it under the legendary
made in brazil name
but regardless of the banner he played
under stewie continued to push himself
in order to help the team succeed
and he further built his reputation as a
versatile star
he doesn't really care what his role is
going to be within the team if it's
going to be what the team needs and is
going to help the team i think a lot of
people would be surprised to hear stu
was a pretty selfless player
and and it is i mean it surprised me a
lot because when he joined the team
we were kind of his inauguration and
like his first pro team
and i was kind of wondering myself how
long it was going to take him to to
really come into his own but
probably even our first international
land he started picking up comms and
doing a little bit more than some of my
teammates that i've been with for a
couple years and played at the level so
um i started noticing that with sku and
then surely enough our first big win
when we won epl in brazil
him and tim were a big part of it in
spite of stewie's willingness to be a
team player
sk continued to struggle and it came to
a head when they bombed out of the group
stage at esl one cologne
mibr taking their time to commit they've
got plenty of it but they've still got
so many aggressive positions scott b
wins his fight but low and ammo a
reloads needed he does have the cross
fire from tizian and the fighting the
kills are firing in tizian's done it
it's just one man left up and coldzera
can't find the final kills
it's big are going to the playoffs and
mib are eliminated in group stages
it was obviously time for a change at
this point and following their
disappointing run in germany
a familiar face joined the mibr roster
stewie's friend
and former teammate tarik replaced bolts
in the hopes of improving the team's
communication issues
the change brought optimism that one of
the most star-studded rosters in cs go's
history
might finally be able to compete with
the likes of astralis
stewie also has a friend now on the team
like an english-speaking friend
and you know he's known me for a long
time as well you know i love playing
with stu
i think that we work really well
together and i think we're going to
bring the heat so you guys got to watch
out
but weeks later at the e-league cs go
premiere in 2018
they went out in groups again picking up
one kill on twist i'm not sure why he
wanted to fight that
whatsoever but um a lot more damage
actually coming in right now and
taric finding another kill on taco and
that's all on turkey almost gets the
transfer
but not quite 16 10 in favor of team
liquid as they pick up the map
win 4-0 against mibr at this event and
unfortunately
for mibr the struggles continue i think
they were struggling
actually having that same hunger that
brought them you know they were they
were working hard
i don't think anyone was doubting that
they're working hard putting in the
hours maybe they were maybe the the hard
work was a little bit more forced this
time and they said oh we we should
we should have these results and this
should just come and and i
i just don't think they were finding
that secret sauce and despite a win at
the relatively small
zotac cup in august of 2018 the roster
just
wasn't living up to expectations
although the team bounced back with a
top four showing at the london major
a series of up and down results made for
a shaky end to the season
just joining sk initially i think that
was a big task
i knew i had you know a lot of pressure
on me because you know you're more like
the new kid on the block and
you're joining a completely different
team different culture
different philosophy of the game and i
think we did really well to begin with
and even bringing in tarik i think we
did a great job i think we did have a
slow start
but i wouldn't say we weren't putting up
a fight against the top teams i think we
were putting up a fight against the top
teams mainly against astralis
and with dupree caught off guard it
falls on to device
mibr looking to push this to a third map
and they
absolutely will they will not go down
without a fight
but while mipr struggled to find
consistency
another north american team faced a
similar challenge
the brazilian superstar taco left sk
gaming to join team liquid but
just like his former team they
consistently fell
short to one of the most dominant teams
of this era
following it another loss to astralis at
the esl pro league season 8 finals
taka requested a trade back to mipr and
in december of 2018 it was official taco
and team liquid's coach zeus
went to mibr in exchange for stewie mibr
got a familiar face
while stewie got the chance to once
again join a north american team
i just want to thank all the fans and
the organization and the players for
giving us this opportunity we're ending
on a good note
and we know how it is we know what we
signed up for there's really no hard
feelings
stewie is someone who steps up
in those spots and and he's known for
becoming a better player
when the pressure is on we think it's
really important to have someone like
that on our roster
that can push everyone forward that can
improve everyone's performance and it
didn't take long for stewie's arrival to
have an impact as he helped team liquid
kickoff 2019 with a win over the
seemingly invincible astralis
at eyebuy power masters so he's able to
get some cover
and he's been great here as long as he
can hold tight to the pillar he's gotten
the second one
nap will fall back into the pit and
he'll take a second one as well
that's it neff seals the deal there was
a slight hope for astralis
but it was liquid the late breaking
horses the whole way
similar to his role with mibr stu
plugged in perfectly as a support player
drawing
plenty of space for the rest of the team
to shine but stewie didn't just help
push liquid forward
he pushed them to the top he's alone he
got pushed in before the flames found
only one
it is available for them to pick up on
entry and bro and wants to capitalize
but do we find the third but now it's
going to be stewie has to get aggressive
good find the first one best chance for
liquid and it's a one-on-one
smoking three but he fires into it and
times it perfectly
he's got the c-set and he's gone it's
all on the jw
smoked away and it's done finally
finally liquid get their notch on the
grand slam
stewie has a smoke elise he can smoke on
top of the bomb that actually helps him
out considering hallo has the off if he
touched this now he actually might be
able to do it al is running in with the
knife going for the splashes here is he
connected
with it looked like he was completely
done for
but he's managed to win the round well
it's pulled everyone away from stewie
he's the only one here first shot is his
second shot is his
bomb is his as well and he's got another
one stewie just tears them all down
he's spotting it out he's gonna be
flanking master setting up and that's
an absolute disaster stewie he may have
just done it
double for him and alicia on the other
side oh my god eminek get a one versus
three
with 19 seconds unbelievable scenes here
ladies and gentlemen team liquid
are your season nine pro league
champions
nails it will he get out definitely does
the smoke actually helps him out here
ct's or lock off electronic is gonna
push through nitro is ready damage done
can't quite find enough though it's a
double kill for stewie2k
bobich knows he has to get much much
closer information that he's that long
and in the open stewie he taps on azus
pistol as well
stewie's got another pistol the knife
does cost them and liquid take the game
in overtime
sideway with a flash that's their best
hole and stewie's been caught but knight
shows there they didn't get stewie how
did she
get away on 14. it's one thing for nitro
to trade it's another to save his friend
friend
his teammate and get the round all at
once smoke on his right
tap on the bomb spray through eight hp
and alex is forced to move
forced to get away and the smoke still
down at least no he's nowhere else he
has to be there
he's so smart he clears everything three
steps ahead
and he gets championship point for
liquid that should do it
there we go it's team liquid and that's
what it means to them
they've taken it in the fourth map the
favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at afl one colon under the belt
and a million dollar bonus unreal the
fashion they did it they never wanted
season one they were so close so many
times
it got to the point where no one thought
they could they brought in that guy
stewie they brought in a trend and they
changed everything
but this legacy is permanent they have
done what no one might ever do again
until grand slam team liquid
in a matter of 63 days
stewie had helped transform team liquid
into the best team in the world by
becoming only the second team
ever to win the intel grand slam
even after becoming the first north
american team to complete the grand slam
stewie and liquid continued to look
unstoppable
they ended the summer on a terror
winning the blast pro series los angeles
and i am chicago with ease what an
incredible show from liquid
they have become hands down nobody can
doubt it the best team in the world
but finally in september of 2019
the team had a rough patch astralis were
returning to power
and the danish dynasty was back in full
force at the berlin major
they took down stewie and team liquid
2-0 in the quarter-finals and went on to
win the major to become
four-time major champions they have just
re-established dominance
forget the hiccup that was team liquid
astralis seems back in a big way
berlin was a turning point for stewie
liquid couldn't recapture the magic
after that loss and they closed out the
year without even winning another event
stewie and his team were once again
living in the shadow of astralis
but even as they struggled into 2020 the
coven 19 pandemic changed
everything for counter-strike forcing us
into an online
era of gaming further challenges arose
when
long-standing member nitro decided to
leave the team in august to pursue a
career in valorant
i think losing nitro actually hurt us
more than we expected
just losing him he was a big he was a
glue for our team he was a big part of
you know being friends with everybody
and you know he was like the middle man
the team keeping the team together
and he played a big leadership role as
well and
losing him we lost like a key player of
our team that
pretty much understood the foundation of
our game and
you know the philosophy that we play
losing nitro meant that stewie would
have to take on the role of igl
something he hadn't done since his time
with cloud9
and in december of 2020 team liquid lost
yet another
core member in twists i actually have a
an announcement to make oh so
on the back of ending 2020 on a very
uh good final it was a matchup that i
could have hoped for um that was
actually my last
games with team liquid and that could be
exciting to
to some people or very bad news for a
lot of team liquid fans
but i just wanted them to hear it from
me the team has since made roster
changes but
stu's motivation has never wavered he's
got a lot of flack i know on liquid
nowadays for
maybe some of his performances but i
think stu
has always been someone who's willing to
play whatever gap
that needs to be filled by a team and i
think it's super underrated and more
recently
stewie has been reunited with his old
teammate fallen
his brazilian friend has now taken the
role of igl
allowing stewie to focus more on his own
game so far
the change has been positive with team
liquid beginning to look more like their
former selves
fallen side of the smoke that flash is
meant for nap to come out
he challenges successfully now all the
no scope
and fallen not able to close just yet
but it's close
and now it's over a 16-9 on inferno from
team liquid at the time we thought
fallen was perfect fit
i played with him in the past he's never
toxic he always has good things to say
um if anything bad to say about him i
think he's a little too nice
i think he's a selfless teammate and he
he's just gonna bring in this different
style that
you know liquid needs and we're gonna
have to put that together
at only 23 years old stewie is still
hungry to be the best
he knows what it takes to win at the
highest possible level
and like always he won't rest until he
does it again
i think it's gotten to the point for our
team that we had to manage our
expectations that we weren't what we
used to be
but we definitely can be what we used to
be if not better once you get that taste
of being the best team in the world when
you're when you were there you're going
to want it back and
that's the biggest drive for us he runs
on in with the opener
sweet on the tray but he's got very wide
with a flashbang luckily they're blinded
off of it and the pistol is out for
perfecto
running him down stewie with the pistol
no ammo and either gun
and it's all stewie2k
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages